Das hatte trotz mäßiger Vorspiele gegen
Mexiko und Schweden wohl kaum ein Fan der
Nationalmannschaft zu fürchten gewagt: Die
Weltmeister, Jogis Jungs sind in Kasan im
letzten Gruppenspiel gegen Südkorea aus der
WM ausgeschieden.
Nach den zähen ersten 45 Minuten und verpassten
deutschen Chancen blieben Jogis Jungs in der
2. Halbzeit weiter bemüht, aber ohne Erfolg.
Deutsche Fans konnten nur verzweifeln.
Daran änderten auch sechs plus dreieinhalb
Minuten Nachspielzeit nichts - im Gegenteil,
Südkoreas Tor wurde nach angezeigtem Abseits
und Videobeweis gegeben.
Dann in buchstäblich letzter Minute der ersten
Nachspielzeit ein weiterer Treffer, ins leere
deutsche Tor: 2:0 für Südkorea.
Lange Gesichter auf der Fanmeile daheim in
Berlin.